We're chopping down the thicket of necessary
federal regulations
by which government too often interferes in
our personal lives and out personal business.
When president Trump bragged about cutting
red tape during his first state of the union address-
We have undertaken a historic effort to massively
reduce job crushing regulations.
-the Democratic response was hardly a surprise.
But Democrats may be surprised to learn that
at the dawn of the deregulation era in the 1970s
it was their party pushing to cut red tape
and shut down entire agencies.
A leading figure in the fight to slash the
state was none other than Jimmy Carter.
There is a limit to the role and the function
of government.
It was senator Ted Kennedy who held extensive
Senate hearings in the early 70s
with testimony from the likes of Ralph Nader
and liberal economist Alfred Kahn
about the benefits of deregulating the airline
industry.
The resulting Airline Deregulation Act of
1978, signed by Carter,
killed the Civil Aeronautics Board, a federal
agency that decided which airlines could fly where
and even what they could charge.
The new competition to the old airline cartel
reduced fares, expanded destinations,
and made air travel an option for those of
us who aren't rich.
On Southern there's only one class of service
and it isn't second.
Carter also looked at stifling government
oversight of the rail and trucking industries
under a Democrat controlled House and Senate.
Result: competition intensified, prices dropped
and consumers saved more money on every day
products.
We've deregulated the air industry, the rail
industry, the trucking industry, financial institutions.
In 1978 President Carter signed into law a
bill that limited Prohibition era restrictions
on home brewing
fully legalizing do it yourself beer production
fostered a culture of experimentation
paving the way for a craft beer revolution
beginning in the 1980s and 90s.
The year that Carter loosened the rules, the
US was home to a mere 50 breweries,
today there are over 5000.
In two generations America went from global
laughing stock to world leader
producing the richest lagers and tastiest
ales.
The Governor of California during Carter's
first Presidency was none other than Jerry Brown
then known as Governor Moonbeam
for his far out musings, glittery social life
and lefty politics.
Yet Brown too could be a fiery skeptic of
government.
And there is an overblown rhetoric and an
overblown expectation
that if there is a problem, there must be
a program to solve it.
In his legitimately awesome second inaugural
address, back in 1979,
Brown said that, quote:
'Many regulations primarily protect the past,
prop up privilege or prevent sensible economic choices.'
The idea that government has some omnipotence
or omniscience
is completely absurd and counter to all of
the thinking that went into this country.
So air travel is now competitive, though it
should be more open to foreign competition damn it!
And the beer industry has been reborn.
But since the dawn of the disco era, governments
at the local, state and federal levels
have imposed entirely new categories of regulations,
such as occupational licensing,
which applied to about one in ten jobs 40
years ago, but now effects one in three.
Arizona, for example, will put its' citizens
in jail for six months
for operating a blow drier without a permit.
Texas wants to make it a criminal offense
to buy pecans without proper authorization.
And Washington DC wants to require that all
day care providers have a college degree.
The aggregate cost of these regulations is
staggering.
Last year, according to the free market Competitive
Enterprise Institute,
federal regulations alone cost Americans 1.9
trillion dollars
or about 15 grand per household.
And while Trump has cut the number of pages
in the federal register
by about one third since he took office,
There are still some 67 federal departments,
agencies and commissions
currently working on over 3000 new regulations.
It seems you can't stop the regulatory state,
you can only hope to contain it.
As Alfred Kahn and his contemporaries could
have explained
licensing boards tend to be dominated by industry
incumbents
who are mainly interested in protecting their
own turf.
Regulation is the friend, not enemy of big
business.
So what has changed over the years
about the party of Bernie Sanders, Elizabeth
Warren and Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez?
Democratic support for deregulation was partly
born out of desperation in the age of stagflation.
Cutting red tape to foster dynamism was about
the last move politicians had left.
By acting now we can control our future instead
of letting the future control us.
So when the long economic expansion and stock
market boom we enjoy now ends, and it will,
the best thing of law makers of both parties
to ask themselves
might just be , what would Jimmy Carter do?